[Musique]
il s'agit de la sécurité des français
seuls les actes importe en cela vous
êtes comptable monsieur le premier
ministre du bilan catastrophique du
président macron monsieur le premier
ministre avec votre nomination on
promettait un changement de cap
ce cap fut tracé le 14 juillet quand le
président de la république en 80 minutes
d'interview acté son échec sur la
sécurité en restant muet sur le sujet
avec emmanuel macron la france et
transformé en un pays où la violence est
devenue le principal moyen d'expression
l'impunité pour les délinquants la norme
et l'autorité de l'état une chimère
comment comptez-vous mettre hors d'état
de nuire ceux qui n'ont pas cette idée
de la france que nous avons en partage
et qui est en notre fierté nationale
en d'autres termes quand comment
comptez-vous sortir la france de la
chienlit dans laquelle elle se trouve
plongée la relance n'est pas seulement
indispensable
elle est urgentissime pour de nombreuses
entreprises françaises il sera trop tard
en septembre
chaque jour qui passe notre économie
dégradé fragilise un peu plus nos
entreprises nos emplois et notre société
tout entière
que de temps perdu alors que nos voisins
allemands et anglais ont déjà amorcé
leur relance
quand vous préférez attendre encore deux
mois de plus que de temps perdu alors
que les députés les républicains vous en
proposer un plan de relance puissant
crédible et cohérent dès le mois de mai
je souligne mon étonnement à minima
constatant que hier dans son discours de
politique générale monsieur le premier
ministre n'a pas eu un mot pour les tpe
pme
nos artisans nos commerçants dont un
très grand nombre souffre de la crise
que nous traversons
en second lieu je pense à toutes les
entreprises pour lesquelles les
exonérations de charges sont
insuffisantes au regard de leurs
difficultés depuis plusieurs semaines
déjà les indicateurs nous alertent le
virus est toujours là et dans certains
départements il progresse à nouveau et
de façon très inquiétante
monsieur le ministre que nous ne sommes
pas sortis d'affaires loin de là et le
chemin vers la vie presque normale
risque d'être beaucoup plus long au vu
des mesures que vous prenez trop
tardivement ou que vous ne prenez pas
nous vous demanderons d'accélérer
évidemment le dépistage des mots des
tests par les tests car nous sommes loin
du conte des 700 milles parsemaient le
niveau de réussite au baccalauréat
session 2020 de la filière technologique
à la filière générale pour atteindre
globalement un record national à 95 7 %
mais le risque de dévaluation du diplôme
n'est quand même pas très loin et puis
il y a un autre effet collatéral
avec ce taux de réussite exceptionnel
conjuguée à une classe d'âge assez
nombreuses
en réalité cela va venir augmenter
mécaniquement le nombre d'étudiants sur
les rangs de l'anp dans les rangs de
l'enseignement supérieur d'environ 35
mille étudiants supplémentaires ce qui
représente quand même l'équivalent de
l'université de notre pour ces classes
moyennes la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation qui était l'un des
engagements forts de la campagne du
candidat idéal maquereau en 2017 est
repoussée aux calendes grecques
une telle décision si elle devait être
confirmée serait en contradiction totale
non seulement avec une promesse de
campagne mais également avec les
engagements du gouvernement et avec la
trajectoire de suppression la taxe
d'habitation prévu par la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
elle représenterait une hausse d'impôts
je dis bien une hausse d'impôt et
rendrai cet impôt terriblement injuste
en le concentrant sur ceux des français
qui ont des revenus moyens
autant dire les classes moyennes
toujours et encore considérés comme des
vaches à lait nous avons du mal à
comprendre à la fois la cohérence et la
stratégie de votre politique
environnementale et écologique
alors que vous êtes là quatrième
ministre de l'écologie en à peine trois
ans au conseil pour le climat convention
citoyenne conseil de défense écologique
autant de paravent pour mieux masquer
vos incertitudes et tenir à distance ses
propositions du parlement est faite de
l'environnement le socle d'un nouveau
pacte de confiance reposant sur trois
piliers économique écologique et social
on en a besoin il nous faut sortir
définitivement de cette écologie
punitive dans une période de grave crise
sanitaire économique et social l'annoncé
de la vente du site alstom de
reichshoffen a été un véritable coup de
massue pour les salariés et leurs
familles la vente du site de production
de reichshoffen pose de nombreuses
questions
quel accord
quel effectif que deviendront les 730
salariés
la centaine d'intérimaires les 130 sous
traitants le site alsacien battent ils
passés aux mains d'un groupe européen où
le loup chinois va-t-il entrer dans la
bergerie européenne l'union européenne
n'était elle pas en train de se tirer
une balle dans le pied en août 2016
le gouvernement est vrai pour
l'interdiction à compter du 1er
septembre 2018 le certains produits
sanitaires de fongicides et
d'insecticides dont d'ailleurs la
non-dangerosité sur l'homme a été
prouvée le président de la république
avait déclaré à l'époque
il n'y aura pas d'arrêt s'il n'y a pas
de produit de substitution
d'ici à trois ans or il est prouvé
aujourd'hui que les produits proposés
par l'amf s sont totalement inefficace
et contre productif c'est tout un pan de
notre économie dynamique agricole qui
est atteinte cette année c'est
inadmissible alors que vous étiez
prévenus depuis des mois de
l'inefficacité des produits d des
risques économiques et sociaux et de
fermetures d'usinés si les bonnes
dispositions ne sont pas prises d'ici à
quinze jours
il n'y aura plus d'alcool plus de gel
hydroalcoolique plus de sucre plus
d'alimentation du bétail
l'état doit être le garant de l'intérêt
général
aujourd'hui c'est le grand silence sur
la fermeture programmée de la raffinerie
total de grandpuits en seine-et-marne
ferme et grandpuits représenterait une
triple faute économique stratégique
politique
[Musique]